This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. Every year, many students who have overcome daunting obstacles in high school receive good news. They've been accepted to college. Many of them are low-income students without standing academic track records, and they represent a success story. The American Dream made real. With hard work, students who don't have a lot of advantages can bootstrap their way into higher education and a better life. Only it doesn't always work out. The rate with which kids who are college intending do not actually get to college in the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维达姆。每年，许多在高中克服了重重困难的学生都会收到好消息：他们被大学录取了。他们当中有许多人是低收入家庭的学生，没有耀眼的学业成绩单，但他们代表了一个成功的故事。美国梦成为了现实。只要努力，那些没有太多优势的学生也能靠自己的力量进入高等教育并过上更好的生活。只是事情并不总是那么顺利。那些打算上大学的孩子在秋季
fall is surprisingly high. This is Lindsay Page, an education researcher at Harvard. In one sample that we look at in the Boston area, we find that upwards of 20% of kids who at the time of high school graduations say that they're continuing on to college, about 20% of those kids don't actually show up in the fall. 20% among low-income kids, that number is even higher.
实际上却没有去上大学的比率高得惊人。这位是林赛·佩奇，哈佛大学的一名教育研究人员。在我们研究的波士顿地区的某个样本中，我们发现，在高中毕业时表示要继续升学的孩子中，有高达20%的人实际上并没有在秋季入学。在低收入家庭孩子中，这个比例甚至更高。
They're getting tripped up somehow right at the finish line. Researchers called this phenomenon summer melt. For universities it's long been a puzzling problem because these are the kids who made it. They took the SATs, they got good grades, they took AP classes, they did their extracurricular activities, they wrote their college essays, they've often applied for and received financial aid. Why wouldn't they show up at college?
不知怎的，他们在终点线前被绊倒了。研究人员将这种现象称为“夏季流失”（summer melt）。对大学来说，这是一个长期令人困惑的问题，因为这些都是成功闯关的孩子。他们参加了SAT考试，取得了不错的成绩，选修了AP课程，参加了课外活动，写了大学申请文书，他们通常还申请并获得了资助。他们为什么不来上大学呢？
In the summer between high school graduation and what would be timely college matriculation, they're falling off track. This week on Hidden Brain, the problem of the last mile and how to fix it. Hello, I'm Austin Bertual. I'm a rising sophomore at Georgia State University. Austin grew up in a working-class family about an hour outside of Atlanta. And from a very young age, he saw college as his ticket to a better life. Growing up, my father worked at a produce standing. He opened a produce standout, on one side out of the military,
在高中毕业到按时入学之间的那个夏天，他们脱离了正轨。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨“最后一英里”的难题以及如何解决它。你好，我是奥斯汀·贝尔丘尔。我是佐治亚州立大学的大二学生。奥斯汀在一个工人阶级家庭长大，家住亚特兰大市郊外大约一小时车程的地方。从小到大，他一直把上大学视为通往更好生活的人场券。在我的成长过程中，我父亲在农产品摊位工作。他退伍后开了一个农产品摊位，
and my mom was an assistant manager at a jewelry store. Neither of Austin's parents went to college. And Austin saw how hard it was for them, even to get jobs in retail or the service industry without a college degree. Austin was an excellent student and a good planner. He took advanced placement classes to help his GPA and to get college credits out of the way.
我妈妈是一家珠宝店的助理经理。奥斯汀的父母都没有上过大学。奥斯汀深知他们有多不容易，甚至在没有大学文凭的情况下很难在零售业或服务行业找到工作。奥斯汀是个优秀的学生，也是个擅长规划的人。他选修了大学先修课程（AP课程），以提高GPA并提前修得大学学分。
He kept his sights firmly on college in spite of a number of challenges. His dad got sick while he was still in school. It was a lot of studying out of late nights. The first half of my high school, I was coming home and doing homework while taking care of my dad. Austin's dad had ALS, also known as Lou Gehrig's disease. So my mom would take care of him during the day and I would come home from school and take care of him at night. It's kind of how we did it. Austin's dad passed away at the end of his sophomore year of high school, and his mom, who had quit her job at the jewelry store when he got sick, had to find work
尽管面临种种挑战，他依然坚定地将目光锁定在大学上。他还在上学时，父亲就生病了。那意味着要熬夜进行大量的学习。我高中的前半段，都是放学回家做作业，同时还要照顾我爸爸。奥斯汀的父亲患有肌萎缩侧索硬化症（ALS），也就是人们常说的渐冻症。所以我妈妈白天照顾他，我放学回家后晚上照顾他。我们基本上就是这样分工的。奥斯汀的父亲在他高二年级结束时去世了，他母亲在他父亲生病时辞去了珠宝店的工作，不得不重新找工作。
again. Here she was in a job market trying to become employed. And she hadn't gone to college. I'm a first-generation student to go to college. And she saw what the market was like, and not having a college degree. There was one conversation with his mother that stuck in Austin's head. I remember sitting in the kitchen and she had just sent out a bunch of resumes and not getting any calls back.
当时她身处就业市场，试图找工作。而且她没有上过大学。我是家里第一个上大学的学生。她看到了就业市场的现状，以及没有大学文凭的影响。奥斯汀脑海里一直挥之不去的是他和母亲的一次谈话。我记得当时我们坐在厨房里，她刚发出了一堆简历，却没有接到任何回电。
And she really just sat me down and said, this is something you're gonna have to do. He had to go to college, so he redoubled his commitment. And he figured out where he wanted to go. He visited Georgia State, a large public university in the heart of Atlanta. I decided I was gonna go to Georgia State very early on in the process. I took a tour here. I loved the inner city school and
她真的只是把我拉坐下来，然后说，这是你必须要去做的事情。他必须上大学，因此他加倍坚定了自己的决心。并且他找到了自己想去的地方。他参观了佐治亚州立大学，这是一所位于亚特兰大市中心的庞大公立大学。我很早就决定要去佐治亚州立大学了。我在这里参观过。我喜欢市中心的学校，
going up skyscrapers in the middle of Atlanta and thinking, I was a school campus here and it was just all these like new buildings and all these people walking around with back backs and going to their classes and I wanted this college to be my college. It seemed like the perfect fit. Not too far from home. He knew he couldn't afford the tuition, but he figured he had a solution. I knew that Zell Miller is the scholarship we have here in Georgia.
在亚特兰大市中心看着高楼大厦拔地而起，心想，这里有一个学校校园，到处都是这些新建筑，还有这么多人背着背包去上课，我希望这所大学能成为我的大学。这似乎是完美的匹配。离家不远。他知道自己付不起学费，但他觉得自己有一个解决方案。我知道泽尔·米勒奖学金是我们佐治亚州这里有的奖学金。
I'm the pay for most of your tuition. I knew I needed that. So my entire high school curriculum, like I pushed myself to get that scholarship. The Zell Miller scholarship would cover most of his tuition about 90%. His father had been in the military so the GI bill would help out with the rest. And then a little bit of financial aid from the university could cover housing and other expenses. So Austin applied not only for college but also for all the aid he needed.
它能支付你大部分的学费。我知道我需要这个。所以我整个高中的课程，都在逼着自己去争取那项奖学金。泽尔·米勒奖学金将支付他大部分的学费，大约90%。他的父亲曾参军，因此《退伍军人权利法案》（GI bill）将帮助支付剩余的部分。然后来自大学的一点经济援助可以支付住房和其他费用。所以奥斯汀不仅申请了大学，还申请了他需要的所有资助。
Around Christmas he learned that all his hard work and sacrifice had paid off. He'd gotten into his dream school. Then, into a letter they did, this is like thing you open up and it says you're accepted and it was a really great feeling I turned to my mom and she got all teary-eyed and it was a great time. He had the grades and the SAT scores for the scholarship he needed. So I'd filled out the housing, I'd done my deposit for housing, I filled, I got my immunizations done. Everything was coming together. And then suddenly he discovered there was a problem.
圣诞节前后，他得知自己所有的辛勤工作和牺牲都有了回报。他被梦想中的学校录取了。然后，他们寄来了一封信，就是那种你打开后上面写着你被录取了的东西，那真是一种非常棒的感觉，我转向我妈妈，她感动得热泪盈眶，那是一段美好的时光。他的成绩和SAT分数都达到了他所需的奖学金的标准。所以我填好了住宿申请，交了住宿押金，还打好了疫苗。一切都在顺利进行。然后突然间他发现出了问题。
Somewhere along the way I found out my social security number had been written down wrong. Somewhere through the system and I wasn't receiving the scholarship that I had worked so hard for. Austin had checked all the boxes, met all the deadlines, done everything right. Like Austin, lots of kids get tripped up right at the finish line. We're going to come back to Austin's story, but first, let's look at the other side of the equation, the University Admissions Office. So I'm Scott Burke and I'm the Associate Vice President and Director of Undergraduate Admissions for Georgia State University in Atlanta, Georgia.
不知怎么的，我发现我的社会安全号被写错了。通过系统的某处环节，我没有拿到我辛勤努力才换来的奖学金。奥斯汀完成了所有程序，赶上了所有截止日期，一切都做得天衣无缝。和奥斯汀一样，许多孩子在终点线前被绊倒了。我们将回到奥斯汀的故事，但首先，让我们来看看方程的另一边，即大学招生办公室。我是斯科特·伯克，我是佐治亚州亚特兰大市佐治亚州立大学的副教务长兼本科招生主任。
Scott couldn't figure out why so many promising students who were admitted to the University were not showing up on day one. And the problem was getting worse. We began to see a creep in the number of students that were not attending in the fall that were at some point in that pre-enrollment process falling off. Scott thought maybe these kids are the ones who are the least committed, the least academically prepared. But then he looked more closely at the data. He found students like Austin Burtchell. And what we found is overall these were good, academically qualified students, with in many cases 3.5 GPAs, 1100 SAT scores that for whatever reason
斯科特无法理解为什么那么多被大学录取的前途无量的学生在开学第一天却没有出现。而且这个问题越来越严重。我们开始发现，在秋季学期不来上学的学生人数在不断攀升，他们在预注册流程的某个环节中掉了链子。斯科特认为，也许这些孩子是最不上心、学术准备最不足的人。但随后他更仔细地查看了数据。他发现了像奥斯汀·贝尔丘尔这样的学生。我们发现，总体而言，这些都是优秀的、学术上合格的学生，在很多情况下，他们的GPA为3.5，SAT分数为1100分，但无论出于什么原因，
we're just not able to continue on with the process. Scott had a feeling that the problem might be the challenges of the reams of paperwork, students had to fill out before getting to college. We have roughly about 35% of our population is first-generation college students. They don't necessarily have the support that they need to go through that enrollment process. In the way that a non-first-generation student would have somebody at home that could help them really guide them through that. They don't necessarily have the same peer group that allows them or helps them to, it supports them to a system. Scott Burke, New Altuel, how much showing up on day one mattered?
他们就是无法继续完成这个流程。斯科特有一种直觉，问题可能在于学生在进入大学前必须填写的大量繁文缛节的挑战。我们大约有35%的人口是第一代大学生。他们不一定拥有完成该注册流程所需的必要支持。就像不是第一代大学生的学生那样，家里可能会有人能真正指导他们完成这个过程。他们不一定拥有能够让他们或帮助他们适应系统的同辈群体。斯科特·伯克，对奥斯汀来说，开学第一天到校有多重要？
Yeah, I mean, this is about changing lives. You know, I'm a first-generation college student. I was the first in my family to go to college. I was the first in my family to achieve a master's degree and it has meant, you know, for me, a better quality of life. So to see students not ending up somewhere was a real concern for us because as we looked at the data as we looked at the information and in the analytics that was in front of us, there was a large percentage of students that weren't ending up going anywhere, obviously. And that was a that was a major concern.
是的，我的意思是，这关乎改变人生。你知道的，我是一个第一代大学生。我是家里第一个上大学的人。我是家里第一个获得硕士学位的人，这意味着，对我而言，生活质量得到了提高。因此，看到学生最终没有去任何地方让我们感到非常担忧，因为当我们查看数据、查看信息以及眼前的分析时，很明显，有很大一部分学生最终哪里都没去。这是一个让人非常担忧的问题。
It wasn't that we were losing them to other colleges and universities. It was that they were not ending up anywhere. Scott wanted to find a way to fix the problem. Lindsey Page, the education researcher at Pittsburgh, says the problem wasn't just a Georgia state. The rate with which kids who are college intending do not actually get to college in the fall is surprisingly high. So in one sample that we look at in the Boston area, we find that upwards of 20% of kids who at the time of high school graduation say that they're continuing on to college, about 20% of those kids don't actually show up in the fall.
并不是说我们把他们输送给了其他大专院校。而是他们最终哪里都没去。斯科特想找到解决问题的方法。匹兹堡的教育研究员林赛·佩奇表示，这个问题不仅限于佐治亚州立大学。那些打算上大学的孩子在秋季实际上却没有去上大学的比率高得惊人。因此，在我们研究波士顿地区的某个样本中，我们发现，在高中毕业时表示要继续升学的孩子中，有高达20%的人实际上并没有在秋季入学。
And with other data sources, we've looked at these patterns nationally and find that rates can range from about 10% to 40%, but we see similar patterns wherever we look across the country. Did you hear that? In some communities, 40% of college-bound kids don't go. And rates of summer melt are highest for kids from lower income backgrounds, especially if their own parents didn't go through the college application process. Lindsay conducted the research with Ben Castleman, who's now at the University of Virginia.
通过其他数据来源，我们在全国范围内研究了这些模式，发现比率从10%到40%不等，但我们在全国各地无论在哪里观察，都会看到类似的模式。你听到了吗？在某些社区，40%的准大学生没有去上大学。而夏季流失率对于低收入背景的孩子来说最高，特别是如果他们自己的父母没有经历过大学申请流程的话。林赛与目前在弗吉尼亚大学的本·卡斯特尔曼共同进行了这项研究。
Ben says students without a lot of family support can find themselves at a disadvantage. Students from middle or upper income backgrounds often have college-educated parents who are familiar with the process and can help guide them through it. If students are the first in their family to go to college, their parents may not have experience with their help. Their high school counselors typically don't work during the summer. They've yet to engage with the supports at their college. And so there's a wide range of complex tasks that students need to complete
本表示，缺乏大量家庭支持的学生可能会处于不利地位。中上收入背景的学生通常拥有受过大学教育的父母，他们熟悉这一流程并能指导孩子完成。如果学生是家里第一个上大学的人，他们的父母可能没有这方面的经验来提供帮助。他们的高中辅导员通常在夏天不工作。他们还没有接触到大学里的支持系统。因此，学生需要在通常无法获得支持的时候完成
at a time when they often don't have access to support. Unfortunately, the financial aid process is far from simple. Many students run into problems even earlier in the process than Austin did. So if you put yourself in the mind of an 18-year-old who's the first in their family to go to college, imagine that you open the mail and you receive a financial aid award letter and that's going to determine what aid you receive and whether you can afford college. Well you need to be able to look at that award letter and distinguish grant aid from the college or from the state or federal government that you won't need to pay back, from loan aid that you will have to pay back over time. And you have to add
一系列复杂的任务。不幸的是，经济援助流程远非简单。许多学生在流程中遇到问题的时间甚至比奥斯汀还要早。因此，如果你设身处地为一个十八岁、家里第一个上大学的孩子着想，想象一下你打开信件，收到了一封经济援助奖学金通知书，这将决定你获得什么援助以及你是否负担得起大学费用。好吧，你需要能够看懂那封奖学金通知书，并将不需要偿还的来自大学、州或联邦政府的助学金，与随着时间推移必须偿好的贷款援助区分开来。你必须将
both of those together figure out how they relate to the total cost of attendance at whichever institution you're planning to enroll at. Depending on the institution, financial aid award letters are often hard to read and hard to digest, even for college educated people. And so for that student who doesn't have access to professional help, they may have a hard time separating out how much am I getting in free money, how much am I going to have to pay back. Does this aid really cover the full cost of enrolling where I want to go to college? And so a month later when they get their tuition bill,
这两者加起来，计算出它们与你计划就读的任何院校的总学费之间的关系。根据院校的不同，经济援助奖学金通知书通常很难阅读和理解，即使对受过大学教育的人来说也是如此。因此，对于无法获得专业帮助的学生来说，他们可能很难区分自己得到了多少免费资金，有多少是要偿还的。这项援助真的能全额支付我想去的大学的入学总费用吗？因此，一个月后当他们收到学费账单时，
the student may be surprised to find that they're going to have to send a check or in some way pay the college considerably more money or have to take out a considerably larger amount of loans, then they realized certainly at the end of high school and maybe even at the start of summer. Obviously failing to show up at college is a huge deal for the individual student. It can change the course of her life. But Ben says, there are also huge societal costs. From when students enter kindergarten
学生可能会惊讶地发现，他们将不得不寄出一张支票，或者以某种方式向大学支付更多的钱，或者不得不借入比他们在高中结束时、甚至可能比在夏天开始时意识到的要多得多的贷款。显然，未能去大学报到对单个学生来说是一件大事。它可能会改变她的人生命运。但本说，这也带来了巨大的社会成本。从学生进入幼儿园
through when they graduate high school, we as a society invest hundreds of thousands of dollars in their academic success. For the students that we're focusing on, that investment has in many ways paid off in that they have applied to and accepted to college and they decide where to enroll and they've graduated high school. By making a small additional investment during the summer to help students overcome those tasks, we can make good on the investment we've already made and continue students on the path to academic and professional success.
到他们高中毕业，我们作为社会在他们的学业成功上投资了数十万美元。对于我们关注的学生来说，这种投资在很多方面得到了回报，因为他们已经申请并被大学录取，他们决定在哪里入学并且高中毕业了。通过在夏天进行一笔小额的额外投资来帮助学生克服这些任务，我们可以兑现我们已经做出的投资，并使学生继续走在学业和职业成功的道路上。
Lindsay and Ben wrote a book together about SummerMelt. They wanted to find a university to test an intervention they had in mind. At Georgia State, Scott Burke read that book and I said we have to be that institution. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Scott Burke and his colleagues at Georgia State University had a problem. A number of students who said they were planning to attend the school were failing to show up on day one, and that number was going up. So when I first arrived at Georgia State, we were at about a 12% melt rate and at its height last year we were at 18%. Scott was at a loss. The school could have hired more administrators to address all
林赛和本合著了一本关于“夏季流失”的书。他们想找一所大学来测试他们构想的干预措施。在佐治亚州立大学，斯科特·伯克读了那本书，我说我们必须成为那所学校。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维达姆。斯科特·伯克和他在佐治亚州立大学的同事们遇到了一个问题。许多声称计划上学的学生在开学第一天却没有出现，而且这个数字还在上升。因此，当我刚来到佐治亚州立大学时，我们的流失率约为12%，而在去年的最高峰时期，我们达到了18%。斯科特束手无策。学校本可以聘请更多行政人员来处理学生在夏天面临的所有
the challenges students faced over the summer, but to serve such a large body of students, it would have been very expensive. They tried emailing the students with reminders, but that didn't fix the problem. We knew that we were missing in our toolbox the ability to be able to nudge students, to do things, and then for us to be able to actually get some engagement and correspondence back from that student as to maybe why they weren't doing it, what was the barrier in place. The social science question here is, how do you, in a low-cost way, help students get through the essential tasks in time? How do you give them access to support without lots of additional administrators? With the help of Lindsey Page, Georgia State came up with a surprisingly
挑战，但为了服务如此庞大的学生群体，成本会非常高。他们曾尝试给学生发送电子邮件提醒，但这并没有解决问题。我们知道，我们的工具箱里缺少一种能力，那就是能够提醒学生去做事情，然后让我们能够实际获得该学生的某种互动和回应，了解他们为什么没有这样做，遇到了什么障碍。这里的社会科学问题是，如何以低成本的方式帮助学生及时完成基本任务？如何在没有大量额外行政人员的情况下让他们获得支持？在林赛·佩奇的帮助下，佐治亚州立大学想出了一个出人意料的
simple solution. They developed an artificially intelligent chatbot, named Pounce, after the school's mascot, a blue panther. The school wanted to do more than simply introduce an intervention. It wanted to test if the intervention worked. So administrators conducted an experiment. Half the incoming students would get text messages from pounds. The other half would not. So what we wanted to do was to measure the impact of the chatbot on the pre-enrollment process.
简单解决方案。他们开发了一个人工智能聊天机器人，名叫“庞斯”（Pounce），以学校的吉祥物——一只蓝色美洲豹命名。学校不仅想引入一种干预措施，还想测试这种干预措施是否有效。因此，管理员进行了一项实验。一半的新生会收到来自“庞斯”的短信。另一半则不会。所以我们想做的是衡量聊天机器人在预注册过程中的影响。
And would it make a difference for those students that had the opportunity to engage with him with pounds? We would begin pushing out nudges to students who didn't do things as a part of the pre-enrollment process. From there, the idea was that students could ask pounds questions as they came up. Let's say pounds messaged a student to tell her the school hadn't received her financial aid application, also known as a FAFSA form. And then what that allowed the student to do is from a natural curiosity standpoint, well wait a minute, I actually did submit my FAFSA something must be going on here.
对于那些有机会与“庞斯”互动的学生来说，这会有所不同吗？我们将开始向那些没有完成预注册流程中某些事情的学生推送提醒。从那里开始，我们的想法是学生可以在问题出现时向“庞斯”提问。假设“庞斯”给学生发信息说学校没有收到她的经济援助申请，也就是所谓的FAFSA表格。然后，这就允许学生从一个自然的好奇心角度出发，等一下，我实际上提交了我的FAFSA，这里一定发生了什么。
And that's when the student can begin asking other questions, when is financial aid supposed to post? When am I supposed to receive my financial aid award? So it allowed the student to take the conversation further and it allowed the student to get faster responses from pounce than they would have if they had just emailed that question. Or if they had called the university, they might have sat on hold, depending upon the volume of our calls, that particular day they might have sat on hold for 30 or 40 minutes before they could get a response to their question.
这就是学生可以开始提出其他问题的时候，经济援助应该在什么时候公布？我什么时候应该收到我的经济援助奖学金？因此，它允许学生将对话推得更远，并且与他们自己发邮件提问相比，它允许学生从“庞斯”那里获得更快的回复。或者如果他们打电话给大学，他们可能不得不在线等待，具体取决于当天的电话量，他们可能不得不在线等待30或40分钟才能得到他们的问题的答复。
So Pounce allowed us, the chatbot allowed us to have students engaging with him and getting responses much more quickly than they would have if they tried to do one of those other traditional ways. The chatbot worked even better than the administrators expected. It could answer about 90% of the students' questions, and when it couldn't answer something, a human being would step in, do the research, and get back to the student. From that point on, Pounds would learn the correct answer to the question, and respond to other students who had the same question. The university saw results for students who had the opportunity to chat with Pounce.
所以“庞斯”让我们，也就是聊天机器人让我们能够让学生与它互动，并且比他们尝试通过其他传统方式获得更快的回复。这个聊天机器人的工作效果甚至比管理员预期的还要好。它能够回答学生大约90%的问题，而当它无法回答某些问题时，真人就会介入，进行研究，并回复学生。从那时起，“庞斯”将学习该问题的正确答案，并回复其他有相同问题的学生。学校看到了那些有机会与“庞斯”聊天的学生所取得的成果。
We found three percentage points less likely to have a faster verification hold on their account. We found four percentage points more likely to submit a final high school transcript. We had three percentage points of the group attend orientation. So a lot of the pre-enrollment check listings that we were monitoring, we were finding that the group that was engaging with pounds was doing these things actually at a higher percentage, submitting their immunizations. Five percentage points more likely to submit an immunization, register for classes,
我们发现他们的账户上出现较快验证搁置的可能性降低了三个百分点。我们发现他们更有可能提交最后的高中成绩单，高出四个百分点。我们发现有三个百分点的群体参加了迎新活动。因此，我们在监测的许多预注册核对清单中发现，与“庞斯”互动的群体实际上以更高的百分比在做这些事情，比如提交疫苗接种证明。提交疫苗接种证明的可能性提高了五个百分点，注册课程，
complete the loan entrance counseling, complete their master promissory notes. We found a 6 to 7% increase in the students in that group, completing these very important checklist items. These are small numbers, but they add up. For fall 2015, we had 3400 students in rule. For fall 2016, we had over 3700 students So that meant 300 more students than we had the year before and we reduced our summer melt From 18% down to 14% That 4%-point difference
完成贷款入学咨询，完成他们的主本票。我们发现该群组中完成这些非常重要的核对清单项目的学生增加了6%到7%。这些数字很小，但它们积少成多。2015年秋季，我们有3400名新生入学。2016年秋季，我们有超过3700名学生。这意味着比前一年增加了300名学生，我们将夏季流失率从18%降至14%。那4个百分点的差距
Maintained increase in 300 students who showed up at school on day one One of the students who heard from Pounds was Austin Virtual. I'm very much a people person and so I like to maybe harass the person and be like, hey, can I get this fixed? But it actually was a little simpler because it's this faster response. It's not somebody going to their hire up and asking questions. It's this faster response and you get the answers you need really quickly and you don't feel this, maybe like embarrassment that it hasn't been done, you know, because it's just a robot.
维持了在开学第一天到校的300名学生的增长。听到“庞斯”消息的学生之一是奥斯汀·贝尔丘尔。我非常喜欢社交，所以我可能喜欢去纠缠某个人并说，嘿，能帮我解决一下这个吗？但它其实更简单一点，因为它的回复更快。这不是某个人去找他们的上级并提出问题。这是一个更快的回复，你可以非常快地得到你需要答案，并且你不会感到这种尴尬，比如这还没有完成，你知道的，因为这只是一个机器人。
Many 17 and 18 year old kids don't want to ask questions, they're supposed to know the answer to already. It's embarrassing. If you haven't been able to figure out something, you kind of want to be able to say you figured it out. And so to have an issue and it feels like you're doing it yourself when a robot's helping you. It's like a tool. Well, like if you're having to rely on somebody else, it creates a sense of dependency. Pound's reached out to Austin in April and offered to be helpful.
许多17、18岁的孩子不想问那些他们本应知道答案的问题。这很尴尬。如果你没能弄清楚某件事，你多少会希望能够说你已经弄清楚了。因此，遇到问题时，当有机器人帮助你时，感觉就像是你自己在解决。它就像一个工具。好吧，如果你不得不依赖其他人，它会产生一种依赖感。“庞斯”在4月联系了奥斯汀并表示愿意提供帮助。
When Austin got nervous that his financial aid had not come through, he reached out to the chatbot. Pounds gave me dates when it would be applied. Pounds told me to go to the fast-for-website to check. And Pounds told me to alert the financial aid office. Austin learned the problem was that his social security number had been entered incorrectly. It was off by one number. The chatbot advised him to come down to campus to look into the problem. Austin didn't know where to go at the school. Pounce had the answer to that question too.
当奥斯汀担心他的经济援助没有下来时，他联系了聊天机器人。“庞斯”给了我援助将要下发的日期。“庞斯”告诉我去FAFSA网站查看。“庞斯”还告诉我要提醒经济援助办公室。奥斯汀得知问题在于他的社会安全号输入错误了。数字差了一个。聊天机器人建议他亲自去校园查看问题所在。奥斯汀不知道在学校该去哪里。“庞斯”对这个问题也有答案。
So Austin got on a bus and came to the university. Within a few hours the problem was fixed. Austin had his financial aid back. He got the scholarship he learned. In that day, they applied this scholarship. And I remember sitting in the office and like my price of college went from the...asker...comically high to like...to very affordable. And I looked at my mom and my mom was crying. We actually went from the financial aid office to the office where you can pay for your tuition and we paid that day.
于是奥斯汀坐上公交车来到了大学。在几个小时内，问题就解决了。奥斯汀找回了他的经济援助。他拿到了他想要的奖学金。那天，他们落实了这笔奖学金。我还记得坐在办公室里，我的大学费用从那个……高得离谱的数字降到了……非常实惠。我看着我妈妈，我妈妈在哭。我们实际上从经济援助办公室直接走到了支付学费的办公室，并在那天付了钱。
Austin got to Georgia State University in the fall just as he planned. He decided to major in political science. He's studying, living in Atlanta, still looking at those skyscrapers as he walks across campus. A few months later, Austin was hanging out with his mom when he got a phone call. The person on the other end of the line says she was with the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation. She asked him about the chatbot, whether he'd used it, how it would help him, and so on. And she said, okay, so the Bill Gates Foundation is going to be interested in doing an interview
奥斯汀如计划的那样在秋季进入了佐治亚州立大学。他决定主修政治学。他在亚特兰大求学、生活，走过校园时依然看着那些摩天大楼。几个月后，奥斯汀正和妈妈在一起时接到了一个电话。电话那头的人说她是比尔及梅琳达·盖茨基金会的人。她问了他关于聊天机器人的事、他是否用过、它是如何帮助他的，诸如此类。然后她说，好的，比尔·盖茨基金会有兴趣对你进行一次采访。
with you. And I looked at my mom, I just like smiled. And then she was like, who is that? Who is that? They were making a documentary about a number of initiatives that had been put in place in Georgia State. Austin did the interview. And then he was told two higher apps from the foundation
我看着我妈妈，我只是笑了笑。然后她就问，那是谁？那是谁？他们正在制作一部关于佐治亚州立大学已经实施的多项举措的纪录片。奥斯汀接受了采访。然后他被告知基金会的两位高层
would be visiting the next day. And so I was just picturing two higher up people, like a man and a woman coming in with a suit on or something and 40 minutes before they leave on the last day they say, oh, you're gonna meet Bill Gates and me and the three other students just look at each other were like what? And we were told you can't tell anybody You have to wait until a certain time and then you can tell people you may have Bill Gates for security reasons. So he comes in, he's extremely nice, extremely polite. He asked many questions. He was super curious about everything we were doing here at Georgia State
将在第二天来访。所以我当时只是在想象两个高层人员，比如一个男人和一个女人穿着西装走进来或者什么的，在最后一天他们离开前40分钟，他们说，哦，你要去见比尔·盖茨，我和其他三个学生互相对视了一眼，我们当时想，什么？我们被告知你不能告诉任何人。你必须等到某个特定的时间，然后你才可以出于安全原因告诉别人你可能见到了比尔·盖茨。所以他进来了，他人非常好，极其礼貌。他问了很多问题。他对我们在佐治亚州立大学这里做的所有事情都超级好奇，
and at one point I actually had to show him how to use the chatbot. And we were about to begin filming this part of the documentary. And I said, first off, sir, it's extremely humbling to explain a software to you. Austin's mom thinks he's famous now. When he thinks about the role the intervention played in his life, he's not sure if it's the reason he ended up at college. But the chatbot did mean that he sorted out the problem in time. He didn't have to jump through hoop, so I'll take a semester off while he waited for
而且在某个时刻，我实际上不得不向他展示如何使用聊天机器人。我们正准备开始拍摄纪录片的这部分。我说，首先，先生，向你解释一个软件让我感到非常荣幸。奥斯汀的妈妈现在认为他出名了。当他回想起这次干预在他的生活中所起的作用时，他不确定这是否是他最终上大学的原因。但聊天机器人确实意味着他在及时解决了问题。他不必经历重重阻碍，也不必在等待经济援助期间休学一个学期。
his financial aid. It was most instrumental because of the timing of it. If I didn't end up having, there's this whole strategy that one person told me about through the system where I was like, well, maybe you'd have to drop your glasses and then just read, pick them up, and you'd get fast, but and that one had been an option for me. I did not want to, I didn't want to, I didn't want to be delayed in my education. So, it was really instrumental because of this timing And it was most important because it led to it coming at the time and needed to. The researchers, Lindsey Page and Ben Castleman,
因为它出现的时间，它最具决定性作用。如果我最终没有经历这个，通过系统有人告诉我的一种整个策略，我当时想，好吧，也许你得放弃你的课程，然后再重新选上，你就会得到资金，而那对我来说是一个选项。我不想，我不想，我不想让我的教育被耽误。所以，因为这个时机，它真的起到了决定性作用。而且最重要的是，它在需要的时候及时出现了。研究人员林赛·佩奇和本·卡斯特尔曼
think that small interventions like this, relatively cheap and simple to pull off, could make a difference for some of the kids who aren't making it through that critical summer window. If these are kids who have intentions to go to college, they are ready to go to college, and we can with low cost supports, improve the rates with which they successfully transition to college on time, then those are certainly dollars well spent. But Ben Castleman and Lindsay Page have found in their research
认为，像这样规模小、相对便宜且易于实现的干预措施，可以为那些未能顺利度过那个关键的夏季窗口期的部分孩子带来改变。如果这些孩子有上大学的意愿，他们已经准备好上大学了，并且我们可以通过低成本的支持，提高他们成功按时过渡到大学的比率，那么这绝对是物有所值的资金。但本·卡斯特尔曼和林赛·佩奇在他们的研究中发现
that some of the interventions intended to diminish summer melt might actually help students once they are in college. They teach students how to solve problems, navigate challenges. The reason that kids drop off in the summer between high school and college is not because of any one big problem. It's a hundred little obstacles like pebbles in your shoe. A financial aid form that requires a parent's signature. Easy enough, unless you have a parent
一些旨在减少夏季流失的干预措施实际上可能会在学生上大学后对他们有所帮助。它们教导学生如何解决问题、应对挑战。高中和大学之间的夏天孩子们掉队的原因并不是因为任何一个大问题。而是像鞋里的鹅卵石一样的一百个小障碍。一份需要父母签字的经济援助表格。这很简单，除非你有一个生病或缺席的父母。
who is sick or absent. A document asking students to make a decision about financial aid, easy enough if you have parents or a guidance counselor who can help, an important deadline, not hard to make, unless you find yourself in a rural area without a car. Our society doesn't like these kinds of problems, but often the difference between success and failure comes down to finding ways to remove each pebble from your shoe often with small and unglamorous solutions like a chatbot. No one might win an award for it, but it can spell the difference between getting most of the way to a goal and crossing the finish line.
一份要求学生对经济援助做出决定的文件，如果有父母或升学指导顾问可以帮忙，这也挺简单；一个重要的截止日期，要赶上并不难，除非你身处一个没有车的农村地区。我们的社会不喜欢这类问题，但成功与失败的区别往往归结于找到方法清除鞋里的每一颗鹅卵石，通常是通过像聊天机器人这样微小而不那么光鲜的解决方案。没有人会为此赢得奖项，但它却能决定你是只能接近目标还是能冲过终点线。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by Tara Boyle. Our staff includes Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parthascha, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle, and Aditi Band Limudi. Our unsung hero this week is one of NPR's lawyers, Ashley Messenger. Whether it's ironing out the details of a contract for a music license or having a philosophical conversation about the nuances of media law, Ashley brings passion and intelligence to everything she does. Ashley, we're grateful for your savvy and your dedication. Thank you.
本期《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·彭曼制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷勒和阿迪蒂·班·利穆迪。我们本周的无名英雄是NPR的律师之一阿什利·梅森杰。无论是敲定音乐许可合同的细节，还是就媒体法的细微差别进行哲学对话，阿什利都对她所做的一切倾注了热情与智慧。阿什利，我们感谢您的精明与奉献。谢谢您。
You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter, and Instagram and listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantan, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并每周在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是香卡·维达姆，这里是NPR。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。